esta puerta en medio de la nada lleva el
túnel que los hombres de la brigada 110
se han convertido en su centro de
operaciones tienen como responsabilidad
la defensa de una de las posiciones del
frente sur de la provincia de saporilla
que después de meses de una relativa
calma ha vuelto a reactivarse en los
últimos días
la imagen que captura uno de los drones
señala como un grupo de integrantes de
las fuerzas rusas intentan avanzar y
tomar una posición
los drones son fundamentales Sin ellos
estamos ciegos
comparte esta información con las otras
unidades para que actúen e impidan que
sigan avanzando
en ciertos lugares el enemigo tiene
deseos de romper las líneas sus intentos
no han sido exitosos hasta ahora
ellos han tenido pérdidas mucho mayores
que las nuestras en este frente
los hombres reconocen que lo más
complicado de esta posición es el
terreno plano donde hay pocos lugares
para esconderse estas dificultades
quedan en evidencia en el camino a
visitar a una de las unidades que horas
antes fue atacada
algunas veces es más ruidoso otras
silencioso usted puede sentirlo
este grupo de hombres la mayoría cosacos
los une que son originarios de esta
provincia de zaporilla que tiene más del
60% de su territorio bajo el control
ruso muchos de ellos tienen todavía
familias en territorios ocupados como
pueden ver están atacando tratan de
entrar nosotros estamos defendiendo el
comandante prefiere continuar la
conversación en el interior
los hombres Bajo su cargo confirman que
los rusos han movilizado un gran número
de tropas en este frente a nosotros
también nos han reforzado y somos más
fuertes no es lo mismo en el comienzo
tenemos más experiencia estamos más
Unidos
desafortunadamente parte del personal de
batalla ha quedado herido o ha muerto y
este hecho nos deja una huella que nos
acompañará hasta el final tenemos que
seguir luchando por nosotros y ellos a
pesar de las dificultades estos hombres
repiten que la única opción que tienen
en esta guerra es seguir adelante